ley Marcial en las cuatro regiones
ucranianas que fueron anexionadas por
Rusia los gobernadores de gerson
saprilla doñez y lubansk tienen la
potestad entre otras nuevas funciones de
restringir la movilidad o evacuar a la
población como lo hacen en gerson
mientras Rusia continúa los ataques
sobre objetivos civiles y energéticos
yendo vivos daños críticos a la
infraestructura hoy tres instalaciones
energéticas Fueron destruidas por el
enemigo por supuesto haremos todo lo
posible para restaurar las capacidades
normales de energía de nuestro país pero
tomará tiempo y esto necesitará de
Nuestro esfuerzo conjunto
para estos ataques los rusos están
usando no solo misiles convencionales
sino drones kamikaze que según Ucrania
son de fabricación iraní y cuya denuncia
sobre su procedencia estaría respaldada
por la otan
todos los indicios apuntan a que Irán
suministra Rusia estos drones y pedimos
a todas las naciones incluido Irán
también apoyen la guerra ilegal de Rusia
contra Ucrania
esa es una guerra de agresión es una
guerra que viola claramente el derecho
internacional y es un ataque a una
nación soberana independiente en Europa
pero Rusia no da crédito a estas
afirmaciones y culpa a la Unión Europea
de enviar millones de dólares en
armamento a Ucrania y acusa a occidente
de terrorista natos
los países que Son miembros de la otan
tienen prisa por culpar a cualquiera
para desviar la culpa de ellos mismos
ustedes no son solo socios el régimen de
kiev son patrocinadores del terrorismo
Europa entre tanto decidió este jueves
congelar los activos de tres personas y
una entidad en Irán por el suministro de
drones a Rusia